une pétition avec 400 signatures et un
boycott de la cantine voilà la situation
au collège de la mauldre à maule
conséquence d'une baisse de la qualité
des repas selon les élèves pain congelé
des charançons dans les lentilles un
constat des élèves et de leurs parents
dont se défend le département chargé de
la gestion des collèges
quand un de vos confrères expliquent que
on a servi un enfant qui portent
témoignage du fait qu'on a servi des
lentilles charançonné lorsque le cuistot
s'est aperçu qu'il y avait des
charançons dans les lentilles
naturellement il les a pas servis donc
elles ne sont jamais arrivés sur la
table des enfants donc aucun appui en
manger face à ces dysfonctionnements le
conseil départemental des yvelines
plaide le temps d'adaptation face à ce
nouveau mode de fonctionnement
la sélection c'est notre associé donc la
sélection ne peut pas ne pas remplir ce
pourquoi elle s'est associée avec nous
donc il n'y a aucune inquiétude
l'inquiétude n'est pas matériel nous
avons besoin de temporalité moi je pense
que fin février tout ça ne sera plus
qu'un mauvais souvenir
sachant que comme toujours dans ces
systèmes de restauration collective y
aura ici ou là des problèmes qui
resurgiront régulièrement et qu on
corrigera automatiquement
ce nouveau mode de fonctionnement passe
par la société d'économie mixte c midi
avec des obligations fixées par le
département à son partenaire la sodexo